تشهد فرنسا في عاشر يوم من الاحتجاجات على
مستوى البلاد استمرارا الاضرابات بعد
اسبوع من وقوع اسوا اعمال عنف في الشوارع
منذ سنوات حيث دعت نقابات العماليه مجددا
الفرنسيين للنزول الى الشوارع ضد اصلاح
تعديل التقاعد الذي مررته الحكومه باللجوء
الى ماده في الدستور اغنتها عن التصويت
على قانون التعديلات في البرلمان وفقا
الوكاله الفرنسيه وفي موازاه خطر الحكومه
تلك او خطوه الحكومه تلك زاد الغضب الشعبي
والفرنسي حيث شارك مئات الالاف من
المتظاهرين في مختلف المدن الفرنسيه في
الاحتجاجات ليصل عددهم في باريس فقط الى
نحو نصف مليون متظاهر وتاثرا بالمشهد
اغلقت عده مؤسسات تربويه كما نفيد الوقود
في اكثر من 15% من محطات الوقود في فرنسا
الاثنين الماضي وتشهد حركه القطارات
اضطرابات كبيره كما الغت شركات الطيران
مجددا بعد رحلاتها ليومي الخميس والجمعه
لا سيما في مطار باريس اورلي بسبب اضراب
مراقبي الحركه الجويه هذا الى جانب
استمرار خنق الاف الاطنان من القمامه
شوارع باريس بعد اكثر من ثلاثه اسابيع من
اضراب جامعي او جامعي القمامه وفق الوكاله
الفرنسيه
بالمقابل اعلن وزير الداخليه جيرالد
دارمانان نشر 13 الف شرطي بينهم
5500 في باريس بما وصف بتعزيزات امنيه غير
مسبوقه
[موسيقى]
لماذا غضب الفرنسيون التدهور المالي
للصناديق التقاعد والشيخوخه الفرنسيين دفع
الحكومه لرفع سن التقاعد تدريجيا من 62
الى 64 عاما
بواقع ثلاثه اشهر سنويا بدءا من الاول من
سبتمبر 2023 حتى عام 2030
منذ التاسع عشر من يناير تظاهر عشرات الاف
الفرنسيين في تسع مرات للتعبير عن رفضهم
للتعديل تعتبر فرنسا واحده من الدول
الاوروبيه التي تعتمد ادنى سن قانوني
للتقاعد
نشرت بلومبرغ عام 2019 ان سن تقاعد الرجال
في امريكا 65 عاما ومن المتوقع ان يبقوا
في صحه جيده لاحد عشر عاما اما سن تقاعد
الرجال في فرنسا فكان 62 عاما مع توقعات
بان يعيشوا بصحه جيده لسبعه عشر عاما
باريس مايا خضراء الكاتبه السياسيه وباريس
ايضا الكاتبه الصحفي اسامه حريري اهلا بكم
فنبدا معك سيد اسامه الى اين تتجه الامور
في فرنسا المزيد من التصعيد في ظل تعنت
الحكومه واستمرار التظاهرات في الشوارع
الفرنسيه
نعم مساء الخير لكم الكريمه يعني هناك
حاله كبت واحتقان كبير في الشارع الفرنسي
واعتقد برايي عن السلطات لم تقم
بالجهود الكافيه لامتصاص هذا الاقتحام
باحتقان بل على العكس مقام به الرئيس
ماكرون يعني رايناه منذ اكثر منذ ثلاثه
ايام عندما قام بالمقابلته الشهيره واختار
توقيت الساعه الواحده من بعد الظهر للقيام
بهذه المقابله ولم يقم بها على الساعه
الثامنه عندما تكون نسبه المشاهده اكبر
بكثير قام بهذه
المقابله وكان يعني في نبرته نوع من
التعجرف وهذا ما يتهمه به جزء كبير من
الشعب الفرنسي حتى وصل بعض المتظاهرين
بانهم يتصرفون كالمتظاهرين الذين اجتاحوا
الكابيتول في الولايات المتحده او حتى
كمناصري ولم يعطي حيزا كبيرا لمساله
المشروع اصلاح لشرح او مشروعه بالضبط
اصلاح نظام التقاعد بالتالي هناك غضب شديد
غضب لدى ايضا الشباب يعني معظم الذين
يتظاهرون اليوم وفق المراقبين هم من من
الشباب الذين يعني ضاقوا ذرعا نوعا ما من
سياسات الحكومه او بالاحرى ايضا من
الطريقه التي استخدم فيها او مرر بها
ماكرون هذا المشروع بالطبع نحن اذا نتجه
نحو التصعيد خاصه وان على ما يبدو الحكومه
اليوم اليوم صباح اليوم قام لو رومبرجيه
وهو زعيم او رئيس اكبر اتحادنا قابل الشغل
الكونفدريه
الفرنسيه للشغل طرح مبادره ومدى اليد الى
ماكرون ربما ايضا لاخراجه من الازمه وفي
هذه المبادره اولا التعليق هذا الاصلاح
وبدء المفاوضات عبر عبر وسيط ولكن سرعان
ما قام الناطق باسم الحكومه
بالرفض هذه المبادره التي طرحها
على عكس الكونفدريه العامه للشغل وهي
النقابه الثانيه في البلاد التي تعرف اكثر
برادكاليتها
رولودريه الشغل في فرنسا معروفه اكثر
بليونتها اتخذ هذه الخطوه ربما لتهدئه
الاوضاع لان النقابات تخشى اكثر من
[موسيقى]
العنفره رفضا كاملا تعنط عجررفه من الرئيس
ماكرون هذا ما يقوله ضيفي باريس هل هو هذا
السبب الذي ادى الى المزيد من الاحتقان في
الشارع الفرنسي
مع كل احترامي للزميل لاسامه الحريري الذي
اقدره ولكن اليوم الوضع في فرنسا خطير ولا
يجب الاسترسال في التحليلات
البسيكولوجيه والنفسيه للرئيس الفرنسي
مكروه ممكن ان ننتقد كيف مر قانون رفع سن
التقاعد بالقوه نوعا ما عبر اللجوء الى
الماده 49-3 عبر عدم ديمقراطيه ايضا هذا
التدبير ولكن اليوم اريد ان اتحدث
بالارقام سنه 1965 لكل متقاعد كان هناك
اربعه اشخاص او اربعه مواطنين يعملون لكي
يمولوا تقاعد الشخص المتقاعد او المواطن
المتقاعد سنه 2050 سيكون هناك اقل من شخص
او بالتحديد 0.67 شخص لتمويل تقاعد مواطن
لذلك اليوم بالنسبه للواقع
يجبرنا او يحثنا على
القراءه العقلانيه لهذه الازمه في فرنسا
اليوم اذا ما انتقلت فرنسا الى هذا
القانون الذي يرمي الى زياده سن التقاعد
الى سن ال 64 ستكون فرنسا في نوع من
الافلاس ستكون فرنسا في نوع من التاخر
بالنسبه للبلدان الاوروبيه الاخرى في
ايطاليا العمر يصل الى 67 في النمسا الى
ال65 في الدوله هولندا هناك
المفاجاه الكبرى يصل العمر الى 67
وتحتسب ثمان اشهر زياده كل سنه في حال ما
زاد امد عمر
الشعب الهولندي ايضا على 67 سنه لذلك
بالنسبه لي اليوم هناك ليونه في نظام
التقاعد في فرنسا ولا يمكن على الفرنسيه
تكبد
[موسيقى]
كلفت البقاء في القانون القديم
خضراء ايضا
اسامه حريري انت كاحد العاملين في قطاع
الاعمال في فرنسا تفرض عليك ضريبه وانت
تدفع بشكل مباشر او غير مباشر
لاشخاص اخرين متقاعدين انت بنفسك تتحمل
جزء من هذه التكلفه فلماذا الاعتراض اذا
على اصلاح قانون المعاشات والتقاعد في
فرنسا
يعني لنكن نوعا ما واقعيا يعني انا لا
بصراحه يعني لا اختلف جدا مع ضيفتكم
الكريمه السيده خضراء بالراي بخصوص مساله
ضروره اصلاح نظام التقاعد انا شخصيا لست
ضد اصلاح هذا النظام صحيح فرنسا مقبله على
ازمه ماليه على ازمه في هذا النظام في
نظام التقاعد
وذلك يعني الارقام سبق وذكرتها ضيفتكم
الكريمه ولكن المشكل الحقيقي لنكن واقعيين
نوعا ما اذا طرح السؤال على اي مواطن
الفرنسي هل تود ان تعمل لسنتين اكثر مقابل
لسنتين اكثر طبعا سيرفض وهذا الرفض ايضا
هو بسبب طرح الحكومه طريقه طرح الحكومه
لهذا المشروع الحكومه لم تقم بالدعايه
اللازمه او بالدعايه الذكيه لاقناع
المواطنين بهذا القانون كان هناك نوع من
التخبط كانت هناك زلات لسان كبيره احد
الوزراء يعني اعترف التابعين احد الوزراء
في الحكومه اعترف بعظمه لسانه قائلا ان
هذا المشروع يضره نوعا ما بالنساء او ليس
بالاحرى لصالح النساء بالتالي كان هناك
ترويج خاطئ جدا لهذا المشروع هناك نقطه
ايضا ثانيه كانت هناك يعني ماخذ جدا على
عندما تكلمت ايضا انا نوعا ما عجرفت رئيس
ماكرون وانا اعتقد ان هذه بعض الامور مهمه
ربما تعني الشعب الفرنسي الذي راى به
رئيسا للاغنياء عندما جاء الى الحكم عام
2017 واول خطوه قام بها هي الغاء الضريبه
على الاغنياء او بالاحرى الاغنياء جدا
بالتالي كل هذه المسائل الطريقه التي
طرحها فيها القانون الترويج الذي تم له
والطريقه التي تم التصويت فيه عليه عندما
استخدم الفقره الثالثه من الماده 49 بدل
اللجوء الى البرلمان او بدل حتى القيام
بنوع من الاستفتاء الشعبي بالتالي جزء
كبير من الشعب الفرنسي راى بان ماكرون هذه
الصفه التي يعني سبق
وتحلى بها يعني عندما اتى رئيسا قالوا عنه
ملك رؤو فعلا انه يتصرف كالملوك
بعرض
مره اخرى اذا كان الرئيس ماكرون اذا كانت
الحكومه الفرنسيه اذا كان الاقتصاد الوطني
الفرنسي يحتاج الى هذا النوع من الاصلاحات
والقوانين لماذا لم يمرر من خلال الجمعيه
الوطنيه لماذا يعمد الرئيس الفرنسي الى
ماده في الدستور تسمح له بتمرير هذا
القانون اذا كان مهم بالفعل لفرنسا
بالفعل لانه ما بين سنه 2017 اي انتخاب
الرئيس ماكرون واخر انتخابات رئاسيه
ونيابيه خسر الرئيس الفرنسي من المكرو
الاغلبيه المطلقه في الجمعيه الوطنيه في
فرنسا لذلك حاول عبر الاستشارات النيابيه
وعبر طرح هذا القانون على كافه الكتل
القيام ببعض من التعديلات لكي يتم طرحه
امام الجمعيه الوطنيه
للتصويت ولكن
عشيه تمرير هذا القانون دستوريا ولكن ليس
ديمقراطيا عبر اللجوء الى الماده 49-3 كان
هناك نوع من الاستفتاء غير الرسمي برهن
للرئيس ماكرون وبين ايضا ان
اليسار المتطرف واليمين المتطرف هم يعلمون
انهم لم يصوتوا على هذا القانون ولكن كان
هناك شرخا في حزب الجمهوريين الذي يراسه
الذي كان منقسما على هذا القانون وكان
كانت كان رئيس الجمهوريه واليزابات بورني
يعولون على اليمين لكي يصوت بكافه نوابه
على هذا القانون وهناك امر ثاني لا يريد
الرئيس مكرون ولا الحكومه الاعتراف به هو
ايضا الشرخ في كتله الرئيس مكروم النيابيه
كل نواب الرئيسي الاول يستطيع الرئيس يكون
ليصوت مع اسامه حريري الى اين تتجه الامور
الى المزيد من التصعيد نحن نتحدث عن
توقعات بوصول المظاهرات والمتظاهرين في
عموم فرنسا الى ما يقرب من المليون متظاهر
من او ما المخرج المزيد من التعرض كما
اشرت من الرئيس الفرنسي ام حل اخر بعيدا
عن الشارع
يعني هناك اعتقد سيناريوهين سيناريو الاول
هو الذي يعود تعول عليه الحكومه وهو
السيناريو ان مع الوقت ان تضعف هذه
المظاهرات نحن نعرف جيدا الكثير من العمال
باتوا غير قادرين على الاضراب ان كل يوم
يتم الاضراب فيهم يخسرون جزء من معاشهم
بالتالي السلطه نعم تعول على النقص في
الزخم في هذه المظاهرات تعوض ايضا ربما
على الانقسام النقابي بين نقابه
يعني اكبر رقبتين والتي اللتان يعني
تعتبران يعني هناك منافسه شديده بينهما
بالتالي السلطات تعول على هذا السيناريو
تعول ايضا على سيناريو ان لانه في الوقت
الحالي مشروع اصلاح نظام التقاعد سيمر على
المجلس الدستوري المجلس الدستوري سيب به
وتعول السلطه على ان يبث هذا المجلس لصالح
هذا المشروع هناك سيناريو اخر وهو نوعا ما
بين يعني بين هلاليين الصمود المتظاهرين
والنقابيين في الشارع والمزيد من الضغوطات
وهنا
يكون يعني ندخل في ازمه مفتوحه لا يمكن
حلها طالما هذا الطرف او ذاك يتعنت
اسامه حريري الكاتب الصحفي شكرا جزيلا لك
وشكرا للكاتب السياسيه مايا خضراء